[Musique]
8h du matin à l'amicale des cavaliers de
l'est
après avoir déposé ses enfants à l'école
jude ex thermea arrive au centre
équestre qu'il a créé il ya maintenant
13 ans mais alors où sont hébergés les
jaunes toujours dans le cas pendant 17
jours
jude ex terme et a été un des principaux
animateurs du mouvement des gilets
jaunes dans l'est de l'île
cérémonial du matin oui c'est le
traditionnel le tour des animaux pour
voir s'il appartient rien en fait j'ai
failli peut tomber malade sans qu'on est
âgé de 38 ans père de cinq enfants
judex est aujourd'hui à la tête d'un
centre équestre de 85 chevaux
pour l'instant mes pensées le maximum
canada's est centré casse à la réunion
rien ne prédestinait pourtant le jeune
homme à prendre la tête d'une telle
entreprise
des bébés là dedans sur un terrain qui
n'était au départ qu'un champs d'ananas
c'est la vie que l'arm lahmada moi comme
ça voilà grandi dans un quartier était
assez difficile quartier de la
cressonnière donc eh bien c'est que à
travers le bon animaux que l'on a pu
exprimer correctement est vraiment
pouvoir sortir de cette délinquance que
ma vraie fréquenté pendant un long
moment
c'est au hasard d'un stage agricole que
le jeune judex se découvre une passion
pour le cheval
il décide alors de partir se former au
métier de maréchal-ferrant
quant à patty en métropole ma paraty
alors le stade à l'époque tout dix mille
francs et comme un bâtiment est prêt
réellement poste rappelle encore jusqu'à
aujourd'hui raconte c'est encore de
moncrabeau midi un évier madame li té
sorte de la rue pont et mamie tu y
arrives litres mais a dit que son
valises gibier à poser 30 sont des
valises sa portée comme ça à moi la joie
près en france en comptant trappes sont
des valises à moi allons comme cela
qu'en arriver a dit mon gazon voilà pour
dames en vain front n'a pas le côté va
affronter un petit billet marron par 20
points à 10 1 pouces d'initiative
apporter aux chances un gars geordie 20
francs multiplier et vingt ans plus tard
la petite entreprise jude externe et à
s'étend sur un hectare 300 et emploie
cinq personnes de familles à s'il me dit
est tous allés à -1 est vrai qu arrive
comme ça où quand l'appareil est
d'autres vies et puis vous fier à mes
yeux plus au travail plus why he ont
plus aucun petit machin ou raymond
données mises bas salaires - vraiment sa
famille pour rejoindre la question des
salaires moins vrai monza il
ici sur africa là à huy et gaia les
gagnants
pour mieux comprendre son parcours judex
nous emmène dans le quartier de son
enfance
ça c'est l'ancien voirie longtemps comme
on était jeunes avec d'autres mamans et
la cressonnière t vient t elle à noter
fouilles à 1 p d'avoir et on m'a pas on
dit un jour du matin on dit dans mon
famille n'était tellement pas ne l'avait
pas les moyens de subvenir parce que
nous mais quand même d'une famille n'est
quand même au total huit enfants
cette plaie pas beaucoup de monde mais
tu es encore bon pour nous c'était mon
école l'école rémois là quand vous voir
et vous mettre tous les matins et moi ça
me rappelle encore comité jeunes ou voit
tout camara des quais coca avec un
limonade
mais quand même c'est un chocolat à -
n'y a rien après tout cela la prends moi
qui ai fait mal et où bouchiba mais la
honte si on essaye de mandali est
manchot ou préfèrent harrach dans son
vin qu'elle est demanderiez morceaux et
loi ce sentiment là aujourd'hui je n'y
comprends mal de monde aussi qu'en
baisse à la point de me comprendre
pourquoi il avait un petit peu comme ça
mais c'est parce que niveau à la banana
mais c'est à nous de faire le premier
pas médiate un besoin d'un coup de main
à l'ambassade de norvège à l'amont case
ça tu es mon cas ça ce bâtiment blanc
ont mis les larmes alors le bateau fait
quand en face la casse donc été pas trop
loin on ne te connais l'endroit nous
titiller s'il rejoint ses deux mutés ou
elle est au même bien à terme magna
sa maman une indemnité les colons sont
galliano l'a fait vous dis souvent le
genre la sauva ou à huy bella soir on
veut parce qu'ils ont été financés dans
des pétards le mythe est mal pays
respecte personne et au niveau - mettez
le matin milliards et me répéter le
swarm est arrimée tp télé
lépine vie nous dit même si il n'avait
pas eu de cheval ou ne reconnut la jaune
à oui ça si la situation c'est comment
voilà il ya des cliques aussi ceux qui
commandent aloi moins que le titre bien
ensemble tout le temps
un jour banal a fait une petite bêtise
et la trappe elena de les morts aetna
deux parties entendent donc depuis ça et
ce jour-là à bourbon bondit la parra -
et ce jour là bas n'était pas avec et
ben c'est comme ça que la l'avancé
halloween est notre petit batave a aussi
noté train de monter aussi n'espérions
quand même chinois et la ja ont hélé
saison nick bien midi à auxerre 1 boucle
a contribué justement à mon avancement
ce la cressonnière je suis tout petit de
munich et le mal à arriver mal à marquer
au val des monts main comme ça d'un coup
et moi pas on dit mme ahadi de monnaie
de façon nos rites et les délais qu'on
ne l'était quartz et comme tout le monde
tu es bien la savate sol semis des cirés
des fois t'es mort aujourd'hui où léa
chef d'entreprise un joli 4 capes à
cause de la rejoindre et les gilet jaune
à colmar les jeunes c'est parce que
moins gênant mais connaît mon histoire
ce qu'on dit a dit et elle l'a tout
simplement me choque c'est sûr si c'est
surtout ça et qu'on me les voix qu'elle
et n'a d'autre chose qu'il parle t il
pas évolué mais il y faut mais pense que
le bon dieu va pouvoir pour aller
et c'est ainsi que j'ai dexter mais
assez retrouver avec les gilet jaune sur
le fameux rond-point de la cocoteraie
sur les lieux de leur combat ils
retrouvent cet après midi quelques
camarades salle est gravé à vis à vis
promet fois de ma vie me fais à fond
contre la pollution m'étais jamais fait
avant la police pense
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
anaïs havas annonce à la fois pour le
prenons maintenant gagner le respect des
sports lannoy gagné et en plus longue
gagner sans bataille sans bulles et sans
rien
et aujourd'hui quel bilan était utile
quand même oui oui ça a été utile parce
que on a vu qu'on peut se réveiller
on a vu qu'on peut être solidaire le
conseil continue on va continuer les
différents noms différemment aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas mettre des gens qui ont
envie de travailler contre nous le salé
normal ça tout le monde a envie de
travailler mettre tout le monde en ville
samedi et s'il faut dire que nous
recommençons il aurait fait autrement
voilà aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
séparatistes et des endroits
stratégiques faire les choses un peu
plus réfléchi raisonné
est ce qui n'entraîne fait là maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la santé à la liberté c'est sacré
la vie c'est un combat dès que le début
et il connaît une femme soit je connais
fouille à nu savoir